[Música]
será que é importante pensarmos sobre
como nascemos sobre como já estamos e
parimos os nossos filhos
nós já sabemos que stress e privações
vividas na vida intra-uterina podem nos
influenciar diretamente por até seis
décadas e indiretamente por até três
gerações já sabemos também a ciência nos
prova que interações ambientais
influências externas podem mudar os
nossos genes nos deixando mais ou menos
suscetíveis a eventos como obesidade
diabetes stress ansiedade problemas
cardíacos e até esquizofrenia sendo
parto o nascimento um evento tão
importante e marcante nas nossas vidas
será que não tem influência alguma um
local ou ambiente de stress violência ou
amor a que somos submetidos a nossa
espécie ela gesto e dar à luz
naturalmente a mais de 200 mil anos
hoje já somos mais de 7 bilhões de
pessoas no planeta então biologicamente
esse é um sistema que deu certo mas
vamos analisar a qualidade desses
nascimentos nos tempos mais primitivos
quando viviam os livros pela natureza
nós fêmeas quando entrávamos em trabalho
de parto
fazia uns como todos os outros mamíferos
nos afastávamos do bando e vamos em
busca de um lugar calmo seguro escuro
para parecermos depois quando deixamos
de ser nômades cultivávamos a terra
tínhamos a nossa casa
geralmente o quarto era o ambiente
escolhido as mulheres da família eram
chamadas a sua ajuda se resume a
esquentar a água fazer compressas
levar comida e apoio para essa mulher em
trabalho de parto
nessa época as famílias eram muito
numerosos tinham muitos filhos e os
portos nascimento serão eventos
familiares muitos de nós hoje já não
lembramos como é esse procedimento de
nascer
quem de nós aqui poderia ajudar uma
mulher em trabalho de parto mas a
ciência nos ajuda a relembrar michel o
dano cientista europeu estudou durante
muitos anos a liberação hormonal durante
o trabalho de parto e ele nos diz que
nós liberamos um complexo coquetel de
hormônios de prazer e de amor um dos
hormônios mais conhecido é o sina aos
toxina ela tanto atua na ativação da
contração uterina quanto na abstração da
dor sim ao estou sim em dose na que nós
produzimos ela abstraia dor
além da citocina também temos as
endorfinas que são hormônios que atuam
na analgesia
durante o trabalho de parto então aqui
nós temos uma dupla poderosíssima o
nosso corpo ele libera um boom de
oxitocina lembrando que esse é o mesmo
orgulho do orgasmo só que em quantidades
muito superiores e um boom de endorfinas
levando essa mulher para parto lândia
porém eu preciso lembrar que para
mantermos esses hormônios em altos
níveis durante horas e horas e horas do
trabalho de parto
o ambiente é muito importante as
condições então antigamente nós vamos
para uma caverna ou para os nossos
quartos termos filhos e hoje para onde
vamos
já vem na nossa cabeça um quarto de
hospital bem claro cheio de
profissionais instrumentos mas por que
um quarto de hospital não pode ser assim
e o parto sendo um evento fisiológico e
não uma patologia
nós podemos sim escolher um
queremos que nossos filhos nação e
porque não em casa mas nós temos um
outro hormônio muito importante nesse
complexo coquetel de hormônios
adrenalina quando a adrenalina é
produzida na hora errada que durante
todo o trabalho de parto
esse processo para adrenalina nos dá
ansiedade taquicardia e nos faz querer
fugir mas quando a adrenalina é
produzida na hora certa e quando a
mulher já viveu o trabalho de parto já
está com a dilatação completa eo bebê
está pronto para nascer
ela também é um hormônio de muito prazer
e adrenalina quando o bebê nasce
ele continua ligado com a mãe pelo
cordão umbilical
o bb também está produzindo adrenalina
então é aquele momento o corpo da mulher
libera mais uma quantidade enorme de
estudos ina e tem aquele primeiro olhar
o em print é o hormônio da afetividade
que vai fazer o vínculo entre mãe e bebê
vai ajudar o bebê procurar a mãe e
aprender a amar mas infelizmente como
muitas de nós vamos partir em hospitais
a única coisa que a gente consegue
produzir durante todo o trabalho de
parto ea adrenalina
aí eu vimos que nosso corpo não
funcionou ou que a dilatação não
aconteceu
historicamente nós começamos a parir em
hospitais apenas após a segunda guerra
mundial no brasil
então fazem cerca de 70 anos apenas que
paremos instituições
um conhecido obstetra gaúcho ricardo
jones nos fala que quando esse processo
começou a instituição passou a ser mais
importante que a natureza e nós fomos
doutrinados acreditar que o nosso corpo
não funciona e nós precisamos de um
grande aporte tecnológico para manter um
equilíbrio orgânico que não é verdade e
de jones nos fala
que os partos passaram de eventos
naturais familiares e femininos para
eventos médicos hospitalares e
masculinos
nós temos uma importante pesquisa
chamada nascer no brasil que entrevistou
mais de 23 mil mães e nela nos fala um
pouco sobre as intervenções intraparto
que são usadas ainda hoje quando os
trabalhos de parto não evolui
uma delas é o soro com ocitocina
sintética
então as mães que estão começando um
trabalho de parto geralmente vão muito
cedo anciosos para uma maternidade que
são colocadas num soro com o hormônio
sintético
esse hormônio faz contrações uterinas
aumentarem então a dor é muito maior e
eu estou sim é sintética não trabalha na
abstração da dor e ela ainda bloqueia a
produção de muitos hormônios naturais
as mães também são incentivados a
ficarem na posição lito tomica deitada
de barriga para cima
notem que nenhum outro mamífero da
natureza escolhe essa posição para parir
deve ser porque em contato com a maca os
ossos principalmente o cox não consegue
relatar que o bb tem que fazer
praticamente um movimento de subida para
nascer
na verdade essa posição sobre a
eficiência profissional que está
atendendo o quarto 36 por cento das
mulheres brasileiras ainda sofrem a
manobra de cristo elege onde elas têm a
sua barriga fortemente empurrada para
baixo podendo haver fratura de costelas
laceração de órgãos internos da mãe
traumatismo craniano no bebê e até a
morte
toques vaginais violentos feitos por
vários profissionais ruptura artificial
da bolsa onde o bebê está dentro alguns
instrumentos também foram inventados
para a retirada mecânica deste bebê de
dentro do corpo da mãe como fórceps
vácuo extrator
nós sabemos a importância que tenha
tecnologia é quando o bebê ea mãe
precisam dessa ajuda
mas em muitos casos simplesmente
respeitar a fisiologia e o tempo desse
trabalho de parto permitir que há uma
escolha a posição ideal iria ajudar
muito no processo que muitas vezes nada
disso precisaria ser usado 81 por cento
das mulheres brasileiras ainda têm o seu
direito a um acompanhante negado
mesmo sendo lei federal desde 2005 nós
sabemos o quanto é importante um
trabalho de parto aquela mão amiga que
ele olhar conhecido mas nós ainda temos
um cenário muito difícil no brasil uma
em cada quatro mulheres brasileiras
sofrem violência obstétrica
isso é muito e nós estamos falando aqui
em problemas muito profundas questões
sociais políticas econômicas culturais
porque não trabalho de parto normal
fisiológico
o que nós precisamos é respeitar esse
tempo ea fisiologia do corpo da mulher e
um trabalho de parto humanizado natural
ele não alimenta esse lucrativo sistema
medicalizado em que vivemos
ele não vende remédios não rende horas
cirúrgicas no brasil hoje nós já vivemos
uma epidemia
o promotor de justiça de aulas ribeiro
no documentário a dor além do parto
ele nos fala que obstetrícia já
especialidade médica com maior número de
denúncias tanto lesão corporal quanto
óbito no mesmo documentário psicóloga
alessandra áraes ela nos disse que as
mulheres que sofrem esse tipo de
violência tem 25% mais chance de
sofrerem de distúrbios mentais ou a
conhecida depressão pós parto
a organização mundial da saúde recomenda
que o número de cirurgias cesarianas ou
partos por via cirúrgica sejam de no
máximo 15%
hoje no brasil a nossa saúde pública tem
uma taxa de 40% de partos via cirúrgica
ea saúde particular a rede suplementar
chega absurdos 84%
em uma cirurgia de extração de bebê nós
temos um risco aumentado de morte
materna de 3,5 vezes o risco de o bebê
nascer com insuficiência respiratória
aguda é 120 vezes maior
o brasil já é hoje considerado líder
mundial de cesarianas
tivemos um problema de saúde público mas
por que uma doula está aqui falando tudo
isso né
aliás o que é uma dólar
bom eu trabalhei durante cinco anos em
multinacionais farmacêuticas
eu estava dentro do sistema e uma noite
eu tive um sonho um sonho muito real
quando eu me lembro parece que eu ainda
estou há nesse sonho trabalhava numa
casa de parto
eu acordei não sabia o que era aquilo
fui pro google procurar e eu descobrir
que na semana seguinte teria um curso de
formação de doulas que também não sabe o
que quer
num outro estado mas o chamado foi muito
forte
eu larguei tudo e fui nessa formação
eu tive uma mudança de vida uma mudança
de paradigmas
hoje eu já tenho três cursos como doula
um deles internacional e nesta jornada
eu descobri que esse movimento da
humanização do parto e do nascimento tem
mais de 30 anos começou em londres e 82
em uma manifestação contra a
artificialização dos partos juntou mais
de seis mil pessoas e eu descobri também
que doula é uma palavra que vem do grego
e significa mulher que serve hoje eu sei
a importância importância da gestante da
mulher escolher a sua do lula porque a
doula é aquela figura que vai retomar
aquela segurança do lar e hoje eu vivo a
dolagem eu sei que a doula ela vai dar
apoio físico e psicológico para essa
mulher em trabalho de parto
a gente atua como douglas tanto na
gestação no trabalho de parto no parto e
no pós parto e na ajuda com a
amamentação
já temos dados internacionais que falam
da importância do nascimento né
nessa ajuda no nascimento esse apoio
essa figura conhecida então nós temos
redução de 40% no uso dessas
intervenções como fórceps e ocitocina
sintética redução de 60 por cento nos
pedidos de analgesia
nós falamos que a do leão analgésico
natural uma redução de 25% na duração do
trabalho de parto
isso é muito significativo e 50% no
índice de cesarianas
eu tenho orgulho de dizer que blumenau é
a primeira cidade do brasil que aprovou
uma lei que garante que as mulheres além
do seu acompanhante têm o direito de
levar uma doula para qualquer
instituição onde vão ter seus filhos
nós abrimos precedente para essa lei ser
aprovada em vários outros municípios
conseguimos aprovar ela também em 2016
no âmbito estadual santa catarina sendo
o primeiro estado a ter essa lei
aprovada e hoje 2017 e janeiro
conseguimos aprovar uma legislação
contra a violência obstétrica que se tem
nos fala sobre isso não só físicas que
eu citei anteriormente que esses
procedimentos feitos sem necessidade já
são considerados violência obstétrica
mas também coerção violência psicológica
recusa de atendimento e foi nesse
cenário que surgiu a nascer amor
hoje já temos muitos frutos no caminho
temos plantão de douglas voluntárias
nós damos cursos para gestantes eu gosto
de dizer que são cursos para famílias
gestantes pois a gente forma uma grande
rede de apoio em um curso de formação de
doulas pra todo o brasil é o nosso
principal objetivo é fazer as mulheres
lembrarem que a gente não só é capaz de
evitar de criar um ser
mas nós somos capazes de trazê-lo para
este mundo também homens e mulheres
todos nós já nascemos e todos nós somos
responsáveis pela vinda desta criança
desse bebê ao mundo porque o parto ele é
muito mais do que um trabalho
o parto é esse incrível portal essa
incrível experiência aonde a mãe vai ao
encontro desse bebê trazê-lo para este
mundo
nós da humanização do nascimento
acreditamos que para mudar o mundo é
preciso primeiro mudar a forma de nascer
e eu particularmente acredito que todos
nós temos uma missão a missão pra mim
significa o que a gente gosta de fazer é
associado com o que o mundo precisa que
seja feito
aproveitem este momento e sintam qual a
sua missão e siga em frente porque cada
passo
vale a pena obrigada
[Aplausos]